- [Female] Do you like that?
- We're going to be trying the Furbo.
Which is a nanny cam for your dog.
There's the capability
to look at your dog,
talk to your dog, and to
throw treats for your dog,
while you're at work.
- I have two pugs.
Technically because I recently moved out,
they're my parents dogs.
But in my heart they're still by dogs.
- My dog's name is Olivia.
She's a mini dachshund.
- My dog is named Hadley.
I have always wished
that I could text her,
when we're apart, just to be like,
hey, how ya doing?
But I can't do that.
Cuz doesn't have opposable thumbs
and the ability to read or write.
Which is a real bummer.
- I used to be able to bring her to work
every single day.
So that's been rough on me.
- I'm excited to sort of get that,
oh my God, I'm so excited
to see you reaction.
- She refuses to get a job.
So I want to know what
she's doing with her day.
- Hello from the floor
of my parent's kitchen.
Me and Sophie are exploring
the Furbo right now.
- I was worried it would be an eyesore,
but it actually goes
really well with my stuff.
- Do you like that?
- It goes through some steps
saying to get the dog acclimated.
Have them sniff it out.
I want to test throwing one of the treats
to see how Olivia reacts.
- I caught her sitting
in front of the Furbo
because that's where the treats came from.
- I didn't realize it threw five of them.
- Definitely sort of
just like the fastest pug
gets the treat, but
maybe that'll make them
exercise a little bit.
- And now for my least
favorite part of the day,
leaving her.
What a beauty.
- Be good while I'm gone.
- Now is the real test to see
if it can cure my pug home sickness.
- Bye.
So I just got out of the meeting
and I'm so excited to check on my Furbo.
I was so distracted just thinking
about how I just wanted
to get back to my desk
to look at my dog.
(laughing)
- I'm going to throw a treat.
Get her out of hiding.
Look at how cute my dogs are.
You can barely see them.
She's so cute.
This makes me really happy to see her.
- Me talking to her
freaks her out I think.
She keeps going to the
door to check if I'm there
and being confused.
So I think I'm going to not do anymore,
because I don't want to make her anxious.
- I think she feels a little bit confused
when the camera adjust focus.
I think she can hear the sound.
And then she'll just stare
right up at the camera.
It's a little funny.
- My family is starting to
get a little creeped out.
Because they'll be in the
kitchen where the Furbo is,
and all of a sudden it
will start gargling,
and spit out treats.
- I feel a little bad
after the treats go out
because she's still looking
at the camera for a bit.
When I check back in it feels kind of sad.
- I think I have given her something
like 40 treats today.
Which is not great.
It's cuz the thing
dispenses five at a time,
and I really want to know where she was
and she was hiding under
the couch, or something,
which she was.
- Maybe it's just like this
longing to be with them
that makes them seem extra cute.
- I feel kind of like
I'm invading her privacy.
- Night mode is kind of creepy,
because I'll throw her a
treat to see where she is
and she's under the
couch and all of a sudden
I saw these eyes pop out.
- It's a little weird
seeing her glowing eyes.
- They look scary.
They look like the twins from the Shining.
Overall, we definitely love Furbo.
Oh, you want a belly rub?
- She did basically what
I thought she'd would do,
which is alternate
between sleep on the couch
and sleeping under the couch.
- It felt like I was disturbing her.
I'd check in and she'd
just be doing her own thing
then I'd be pelting her with treats.
- It did make me miss
her more during the day,
but that's honestly the
life of someone obsessed
with their dog.
- I definitely liked it
more than my dogs did.
My dogs didn't dislike
it but I don't think
they knew that it was me talking to them.
- She has complained
about her privacy rights,
and I don't blame her.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)